what's up elimination it's Evan if you
are going to be in Atlanta this Monday
holiday Monday October 9th I am gonna be
there and I want to meet up with you
guys and have some coffee talk shop take
some pictures help you with your
business
I am surprising Nina it's a long weekend
for us so it's Thanksgiving for us that
is Columbus Day for you guys watching
I'm surprising Nina with a trip to
Atlanta because her best friend from
growing up that lives in Atlanta we
haven't seen her in a long time and we
actually have three days off here with
no responsibilities and so I thought
let's go to Atlanta well surprise Nina
we're gonna spend the weekend with her
friend on Monday I'm flying out but I
have some time in the morning I'm
looking at Monday at 11 o'clock Atlanta
time to have a quick Meetup
go to a coffee shop my god I think two
hours free so one if you guys are close
if you can make it Atlanta area 11 a.m.
on Monday October 9th please email my
assistant Sandra at Evan Carmichael comm
and also to if you have any
recommendations for a coffee shop that
we should be going to to do the Meetup
something that has some tables someplace
to breathe so we're not like all crammed
into one little tiny corner then also
please email Sandra we'll pick a place
and send you will email everybody I
guess to Sunday where we're gonna be
it's gonna be 11 o'clock on the monday
somewhere in the atlanta area
i always love meeting up with fans and
subscribers and when I travel it's not
always possible because there's been a
lot of family stuff but we have a couple
days Nina's getting here a couple days
on and so we've got this one little
piece of time before I fly back to
Toronto I would love to meet you again
take some pictures sign some books maybe
I'll bring some books with me give
something away do a little contest we'll
see we'll see what happens but I love
meeting you guys answering questions
helping you with the business it's great
to be able to put you know face to the
names into the people that I've seen the
comments and to make it a little more
real you know shake some hands hopefully
you can make it I'll see you there we'll
have a lot of fun again remember to
email
you're gonna come if you're interested
sandra epic Carmichael calm if there's
no cost we're just gonna meet up at a
coffee shop and have some good talk
together hope to see you there thank you
guys so much to the love hope you have a
fantastic weekend I guess I need to tell
Nina cuz she's gonna find out from this
video that we're leaving and where we're
going so this kind of supposed to
surprise a little bit but that is okay
I want to meet up with you guys and it's
worth it so thank you guys for watching
hope you'll see you in Atlanta continue
to believe and whatever your one word is
much love guys see you soon